Let's see the solution for the performance comparison quiz. We had a laptop
that takes four hours to compress this video. This is a latency, so the speed up
of new versus old will be the old latency divided by the new latency.
Four hours is 240 minutes. The new latency is 10 minutes,
so the speedup is 24. So the correct answer
here is 24. Intuitively, a speed of larger
than one means that the new thing is actually
faster than the old thing. Speedups less than
one mean that the new thing is actually slower.
So if you divide the wrong things here,
if you took, for example, 10 over 240, you
would have gotten something like 0.04. And at that
point, you can check the new thing is actually
significantly faster. So if you're getting a number that is much
lower than one, that probably means you're dividing the numbers wrongly.